6 26 on your 4th of july here at driving  you crazy we are revisiting a frequent  email complaint  patrick writes that what's driving him  crazy is the abundance of cars on the  road with expired tags did i miss a memo  can i stop paying for my registration  and insurance if it's not required  anymore in my apartment complex i  counted 27 cars with expired tags  well patrick if this was one of those  courtroom dramas from tv an attorney  might say asked and answered your honor  i mean it is true  we get this question all the time and it  keeps coming up so i will go ahead and  check in with the men and women of  southern nevada law enforcement with  their responses in a future what's  driving the crazy report for today  buckle up drive carefully and please put  down that phone something's driving you  crazy email me traffic eight at  eightnewsnow.com